bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat au programme
cet après-midi la poursuite de l'examen
de la réforme ferroviaire
l'objectif de ce texte est de stabiliser
la dette du secteur ferroviaire une
dette évaluée à 44 milliards d'euros
mais il s'agit également de préparer son
ouverture totale à la concurrence
rappelez vous c'est cette réforme qui
avait généré 14 jours de grève sncf lors
de son examen à l'assemblée nationale ce
matin les sénateurs ont notamment adopté
l'article premier du texte
cet article définit le système de
transport ferroviaire nationale ainsi
que la composition et le fonctionnement
du groupe public ferroviaire et de son 1
pci de tête dénommé sncf le sénat a
également adopté un article additionnel
après l'article 1er afin de stabiliser
le régime des surtaxes local temporaire
désormais donc les investissements dans
les gares seront financées par une très
légère hausse du prix des billets des
trains cet après-midi le sénat reprend à
l'article 2 un article qui fixe un
gestionnaire d'infrastructure unifiée
sncf réseau et détermine ses modalités
de fonctionnement mais tout de suite
direction l'hémicycle poursuivre
l'examen de ce texte très bonne après
midi avec nous sur public sénat
la séance et reprises
j'informe le sénat que la commission du
développement durable a fait connaître
qu'elle a procédé à la désignation des
candidats aux éventuels commission mixte
paritaire chargée de proposer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi portant
réforme ferroviaire
et de la proposition de loi organique
relative à la nomination des dirigeants
de la sncf actuellement en cours
d'examen cette liste a été publié
conformément à l'article 12 alinéa 4 du
règlement et sera ratifié si aucune
opposition n'est fait dans le délai
d'une heure
nous reprenons la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée
portant réforme ferroviaire
dans la discussion des articles monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues nous
sommes parvenus à l'amendement numéro 10
au sein de l'article deux
amendements numéro 10 qui est présentée
par monsieur dès qu'il aura
rejoint sa place
mais si monsieur neige ne veut pas
présenté cet amendement on ne lui
reprochera pas à le voilà
monsieur le président merci excusez moi
voilà donc les pics de tête cncf
présidée par le président de sncf
mobilité ne doit pas interférer dans
l'exercice des fonctions essentielles
qui sont chez sncf réseau la convocation
d'un conseil d'administration restreint
sans représentant de l'epic de tête pour
les questions touchant la gestion des
fonctions essentielles permet d'assurer
le respect de l'article 7 paragraphe 2
de la directive 2000 13 34 qui impose
l'indépendance juridique organisationnel
et décisionnel de la gestion des
fonctions essentielles par le
gestionnaire d'infrastructure à l'égard
des entreprises ferroviaires et de la
holding
l'indépendance de gestion des fonctions
essentielles par sncf réseau et donc un
point fondamental pour rendre le modèle
de gouvernance français euro compatibles
merci cher collègue monsieur
capo-canellas si vous avez un amendement
89 à ses voisins pour ne pas dire
identique merci monsieur le président il
est effectivement identique je vais pas
être très lourd d'autant plus que nous
avons déjà eu l'occasion depuis hier
d'aborder souvent
ces questions nous considérons que les
pics de tête ne doit pas interférer dans
l'exercice des fonctions essentielles
par sncf réseau aussi la convocation
d'un conseil d'administration restreint
sans représentant les pics de tête pour
les questions touchant la gestion des
fonctions essentielles nous paraît pas
nous paraît mieux assurer le respect de
l'article 7 paragraphe 2 de la directive
2000 12-34 uae qui impose l'indépendance
juridique organisationnel et décisionnel
de la gestion des fonctions essentielles
par la gestionnaire d'infrastructure à
l'égard des entreprises ferroviaires et
de la holding merci cher collègue
monsieur testons mais se rapporte à
l'avis de la commission
merci monsieur le président
ces deux amendements visent à instaurer
une formation restreinte du conseil
d'administration de sncf réseau dans
laquelle ne seraient pas présents les
représentants de la sncf pour statuer
sur des questions relatives à la gestion
des deux fonctions essentielles
la commission des blancs durable a
considéré que la présence d'un tiers de
représentants de la sncf au conseil
d'administration de la sncf réseau ne
remettait pas en cause l'indépendance
décisionnel du conseil d'administration
du gestionnaire d'infrastructure la
commission a estimé aussi que la mise en
place de cette formation restreinte
telle que vous la proposer ne semble pas
nécessaire avis défavorable de la
commission merci monsieur le ministre
mais nous avons eu l'explication
nombreuses reprises concernant la
philosophie du texte est donc double
avis défavorable avis défavorable pas
d'explications de vote je me revois ces
deux amendements qui est son tour
contre
abstentions ils ne sont pas adoptées un
moment 129 rectifié van hamme escoffier
dans monsieur le ministre
l'article 2 de notre projet de loi
actuellement accorde à la raf pouvoir
d'opposition à la raf dont on a dont on
sait ce que l'on a voulu en faire pour
lui donner une véritable force en
matière de régulation des activités
ferroviaires donc la raf a un pouvoir
d'opposition à la révocation du
président de sncf réseau motivée par
l'indépendance dont celui ci peut avoir
fait preuve au cours de l'exercice de
ses fonctions à l'égard des intérêts de
sncf mobilité mais la rédaction telle
qu'elle est ne garantit pas nous
semble-t-il suffisamment l'indépendance
du président de sncf réseau et c'est
pourquoi il convient d'étendre cette
disposition à toutes les entreprises
ferroviaires c'est le sens de notre
amendement merci cher collègue monsieur
le rapporteur
chez bien évidemment à l'égard de
l'ensemble des entreprises ferroviaires
que le président du conseil
d'administration de la sncf réseau devra
faire preuve d'indépendance
la commission a donc considéré que
l'amendement d'anne marie escoffier
était tout à fait justifié avis
favorable
monsieur le ministre à mon tour
d'exprimer un avis favorable à votre
amendement bowdam le ministre je vais
maintenant voir cet amendement 129
rectifier pour
contre abstentions il est adopté un
amendement numéro 11
monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur michaud
collègues conformément aux
recommandations formulées par l'autorité
de la concurrence
l'interdiction de prise de
responsabilité dans une entreprise
ferroviaire prévue par l'article l 21 11
tirs et 16-1 devrait également être
étendue au-delà de la notion de
dirigeant cette interdiction devrait
aussi s'appliquer à tout le personnel
sensible de la sncf réseau gérant des
fonctions essentielles notamment les
attributions des tarifications des
sillons
c'est cher collègue monsieur testant
pour les personnels autre que les
dirigeants ayant connaissance
d'informations à caractère commercial
les règles applicables sont celles de la
confidentialité je vous renvoie à
l'article 3 du projet de loi à ce sujet
et par ailleurs une commission de
déontologie
veille à ce que cette confidentialité
soit préservée y compris y compris
pardon après la cessation des fonctions
ces personnels n'ayant pas de capacité
personnelle à prendre des décisions
pouvant avoir un impact sur les
entreprises ferroviaires ce régime déjà
très contraignant est suffisant c'est la
raison pour laquelle la commission a
émis un avis défavorable à l'amendement
numéro 11 merci son rapporteur monsieur
le ministre oui même avis la commission
de déontologie existe depuis longtemps
et assume ses fonctions donc défavorable
explications de vote je me revois qui
est pour
je disais que c'était l'amendement que
je m'étais aux voix qui est pour
qui est contre
et s'abstient il n'est pas adopté un
amendement numéro 90 monsieur
capo-canellas
oui merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues cet article de créer un
article l 2111 qui reste 16-2 au sein du
code des transports qui crée une
commission d anthologie du ferroviaire
cette commission sera consulté lorsque
le président du conseil administration
de sncf réseau un dirigeant de sncf
réseau ou un membre du personnel sncf
réseau souhaitera exercer des activités
pour le compte d'une entreprise exerçant
directement ou par l'intermédiaire d'une
de ses filiales une activité entreprises
ferroviaires avant l'expiration d'un
délai de trois ans après la cessation de
ses fonctions
le rôle de la commission de déontologie
nous paraît tout à fait utile pour
régler ces questions de conflits
d'intérêts qui pourraient se présenter
au sein du système ferroviaire et
garantir donc des pratiques
discriminatoires entre opérateurs
ferroviaires afin de renforcer ses
intentions
qu'il me soit permis à monsieur ministre
de sacrifier à ma passion pour la raf
que vous avez dénoncé fort gentiment de
fortes aimablement ce matin avec des
mots choisis et donc qu'il me soit
permis de vous proposer que la raf
justement soient consultés par la
commission de déontologie avant de
rendre son avis sur ces questions sans
que le régulateur peut apporter une
expertise utile dans ces matières
merci cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur
il a semblé à la commission du
développement durable que les
compétences de la raf avait été déjà
considérablement étendu
cette consultation
quelques vous la proposer à l'amendement
numéro 90 ch n'a pas paru absolument
indispensable à la commission tout le
monde a considéré qu'il était préférable
que la raf se concentrent absolument sur
son coeur de métier
avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre je sais je
vous décevoir
mais dès lors qu'il s'agit de parler de
l'afld
je suis attentif aux préconisations et
votre attention tout à fait particulière
ceci étant il faut aussi de la
simplification on la procédure que vous
préconisez aurait pour effet d'alourdir
inutilement le processus devant la
commission de déontologie aussi avis
défavorable je vais mettre voir cet
amendement qui est pour
contre
abstentions il n'est pas adopté 130
rectifié madames cultive monsieur le
président dans un souci de cohérence et
d'efficacité je retire cet amendement
moment et retirer une discussion commune
l'amendement est un sous-amendement 176
monsieur capo-canellas
merci monsieur le président
la maman 110 revêt à nos yeux une
certaine importance non pas que le le
précédent où les précédents en émoi mais
celui ci touche à un sujet que nous
avons déjà évoqué nous avons été
nombreux orateurs à aborder cette
question
lors de l'ensemble de la discussion
générale et au fil des premiers les
amendements que nous avons examiné il
s'agit bien sûr de la question de la
dette cet amendement s'inscrit donc dans
l'un des enjeux principal de ce texte à
savoir la question la dette qui est
porté par rff aujourd'hui et qui sera
portée demain par sncf réseau comme j'ai
eu l'occasion de le rappeler en
discussion générale notre groupe se
souhaite davantage inscrire la
stabilisation voire la diminution de la
dette comme une des priorités du système
ferroviaire français inutile de rappeler
ici le rythme de sa progression qui
pourrait nous conduire en 2025 à près de
70 milliards d'endettement pour
le réseau pour cela c'est un moment
prévoit d'obliger entre guillemets la
sncf réseau a publié chaque année le
niveau de la dette reclassé dans la
dette publique qui est aujourd'hui
estimé à 10 milliards 8 parmi la dette
de rff on sait tous que l'idh c'est un
art classé 10 milliards 8 comme dette
publique donc l'idée c'est d'obliger
sncf a publié chaque année le niveau de
cette d'être classé à défaut de réels
efforts sur l'amélioration de la
performance du réseau et de la
productivité des acteurs du ferroviaire
notre système serait nous semble-t-il en
danger de mort si la dette continuer à
progresser à ce rythme cela conduirait
peut-être aussi à faire des choix si cet
amendement a été adopté je souhaite à
faire des choix sur la consistance et de
périmètre des investissements et du
réseau cette publication annuelle
pourrait servir de prise de conscience
est ramené à ce que des éléments pour
agir vite et mieux soit réellement
débattus et pris en compte encore une
fois ce sujet de la dette ne peut pas
être contourné j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire comme beaucoup d'autres orateurs
issus à nous paraîtrait en tout cas un
progrès je remercie
merci mais sa collègue monsieur le
rapporteur
sur le président chères et chers
collègues nous touchons là un des points
très importants de ce projet de loi en
effet tout le monde sait bien que la
dette est un élément qui vient peser
très lourdement sur la capacité
d'investissement
du gestionnaire d'infrastructure qui
sera désormais réunifié
alors dans ces conditions sur le
président qui ne voyaient pas
d'inconvénient je donnerais en même
temps mon avis sur l'amendement 110 de
vincent capo-canellas et je vous
présenterai le sous-amendement
165 bien sûr
tout le monde considère qu'il est
important que sncf réseau fasse le point
chaque année sur le montant de sa dette
reclassé dans la dette des
administrations publiques tout le monde
sait aujourd'hui qu'une partie de la
dette est supporter de façon
artificielle par rff cette dette ne peut
pas être amorti par l'établissement et
elle est de fait monsieur le ministre
garanties par l'état l'insee vient
d'ailleurs de requalifier 10 8 milliards
d'euros de la dette de rff en dette
publique il convient donc de rendre
cette opération transparente et visible
par tous donc je vous propose de
sous-amendé l'amendement numéro 110 afin
que cette information figure au rapport
annuel d'activités de sncf réseau
accompagné des perspectives d'évolution
de cette d'être reclassés il me semble
que il faut préciser l'amendement qui a
été déposée par le groupe u10 uc et
c'est ce que je vous propose de faire
avec mon sous-amendement
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur
capo-canellas ce pour éviter que vous
n'ayez recours un scrutin public
le sorte que vous ayez une majorité et
comme le dit monsieur le rapporteur
c'est une question très importante nous
l'avons souligné à plusieurs reprises
la question de la dette la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre donc je
donnerai tout en vous privant du recours
au scrutin public un avis favorable à
votre amendement un avis favorable sous
amendement
explications de vote monsieur
le groupe ump soutiendra cet excellent
sous-amendement
monsieur capo-canellas ce oui merci
monsieur le ministre effectivement la
parole publique du ministre vaut au
moins autant qu'un scrutin public donc
je vous en remercie et puis je suis
favorable au sous-amendement présenté
par le rapporteur que je remercie pour
sa compréhension du sujet et des sons
sens du débat parlementaire
vient mais chers collègues je vais
mettre aux voix ce sous amendement
qui est favorable
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté et jeu mais l'amendement qui est
pour
contre
abstentions et bien voilà une image
humaine unanimité
qui devrait faciliter notre après midi
l'amendement numéro 55 madame cherche
à vous merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le présent amendement que j'avais déjà
présenté lors de la discussion de la loi
portant régulation du système
ferroviaire en 2009 vise à prendre en
compte dans le calcul des redevances les
missions de service public
retenu par la collectivité mais aussi
l'intérêt social et environnemental de
son utilisation nous souhaitons et une
telle disposition a clairement sa place
dans ce projet de loi notre avis que le
calcul de la redevance varie en fonction
de l'utilité des lignes de leur
rentabilité et du caractère plus ou
moins énergivore du train ainsi pour
prendre un exemple l'utilisation de
matériel de traction diesel par certains
opérateurs sur des lignes électrifiées
pourrait être pénalisée en augmentant
les péages tandis que celle des rames de
tgv à deux étages moins consommatrices
de sion pourrait donc être encouragée
par une minoration de ses péages la mode
il à la modulation des péages a été
proposée dans un rapport d'information
de la commission des affaires
économiques sur les infrastructures qui
remonte à 2007 rapport adopté à
l'unanimité
cette possibilité de modulation s'avère
en effet indispensable pour optimiser la
gestion des flux et l'utilisation des
réseaux pour augmenter les tarifs sur
les lignes à haute rentabilité et
diminuer les pelles à les péages sur les
lignes économiquement plus fragiles ou
qui assurent des missions de service
public ainsi que pour favoriser les
comportements vertueux en matière de
développement durable
venant pour ma part le département
relativement enclavé je mesure l'intérêt
d'une modulation des péages pour une
péréquation efficace entre les lignes
rentables et celles qui le sont moins
si je prends le cas de mon département
l'allier et de départements voisins
comme la creuse la fermeture de lignes
secondaires entraîné le report modal du
rail vers la route dans le cadre de la
libéralisation annoncées par le
quatrième paquet ferroviaire et si l'on
ne règle pas cette question on risque de
mettre sncf mobilité en difficulté et on
pénalisera les investissements sur les
trains de la vie quotidienne qui
représentent 90% du trafic les péages
doivent donc tenir compte à notre avis
de ses services d'intérêt général et de
la nécessaire compensation à
l'entreprise qui les assument la
modulation des péages doit aussi inciter
à des comportements vertueux et c'est
pour cela que nous vous présentons c'est
cet amendement
merci monsieur le rapporteur
l'amendement présenté par mireille
schurch au nom de son groupe
prévoit que le calcul des péages ne
tient de plus compte de l'harmonisation
des conditions de la concurrence
intermodal comme le prévoit pourtant le
code des transports mais tiennent compte
des missions de service public retenu
par la collectivité et de l'intérêt
social et environnemental de son
utilisation
cette question a fait débat devant la
commission qui a considéré qu'il est
essentiel que la tarification de
l'infrastructure tiennent quand de
l'harmonisation des conditions de la
concurrence intermodal faute de quoi le
risque existerait d'accélérer le report
du transport ferroviaire vers la route
et c'est la raison pour laquelle la
commission a émis un avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre
également avis défavorable sur le
président un vide et sarralbe je vais
mettre voit cet amendement 55 pour
contre abstentions il n'est pas adoptée
965 ce cap au canada ce
merci je suis président la ligne à 80 de
cet article 2 dispose que tant que le
coût complet du réseau n'est pas couvert
par l'ensemble de ses ressources
sncf réseau conservent le bénéfice des
gains de productivité qu'ils réalisent
aussi l'amendement proposé vise à
transposer une partie des directives
2012 34e qui prévoit que le gestionnaire
d'infrastructure et malgré tout
encouragé par des mesures d'incitation à
maîtriser s'écoute
merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président la
commission a d'abord considéré que
cette disposition
une faible portée normative
par ailleurs elle a aussi rappelé que
des mesures d'incitation sont déjà
prévues dans le texte ainsi le contrat
conclu entre sncf réseau et l'état
détaillera les mesures prises pour
maîtriser les dépenses de gestion de
l'infrastructure et objectifs de
productivité retenue il est en outre
précisé alinéa 79 que sncf réseau
conservent le bénéfice de ces gains de
productivité
tant que le coût complet
du réseau n'est pas couverte par ses
ressources il nous semble donc que la
rédaction actuelle de cet alinéa et plus
généralement de l'article
donc répondent tout à fait aux
préoccupations légitimes l'auteur de
l'amendement je demande donc de retirer
son amendement sinon j'y mettrai au nom
de la commission d'avis défavorables les
mains sales ministre
je ne sais pas si monsieur le
moteur le moment va répondre
favorablement à la demande de retrait
quelqu'un je n'aurai pas à me prononcer
mais enfin ça m'ennuierait de vous
donner un avis défavorable monsieur
capo-canellas
be nice
alors monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
président je vais éviter d'obliger
monsieur ministre a donné un avis
défavorable
donc je vais je vais retirer volontiers
cet amendement n'est entendu les
explications du rapporteur et à néant
imaginer la vie convergent du du
ministre ce qui m'aurait m'étonne pas
d'ailleurs l'amendement est donc retiré
l'amendement numéro 69 cherche à l'âme
didier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous avons
présenté cet amendement pour dire que le
réseau ferroviaire est propriété de la
nation
les biens immobiliers qui sont gérés par
la sncf appartiennent à l'état et lui
ont toujours appartenu depuis 1937
c'était le cas des infrastructures avant
la création de rff vnf et autres qu'on
dit propriétaire aujourd'hui les 30000
km de ligne ferroviaire qui irrigue la
france représente un formidable atout
pour l'aménagement du territoire la
promotion d'une politique industrielle
de l'emploi au service du développement
de nos territoires
il faut garder à l'esprit qu'on ne
construit pas on ne maintient pas le
réseau par plaisir mais parce qu'il y a
un besoin démographiques géographiques
économiques des tâches et des logiques
de rentabilité pur c'est pourquoi pour
les sénateurs du groupe crc
l'infrastructure ferroviaire est un
patrimoine national
le patrimoine de la collectivité après
tous les usagers et les contribuables
qui ont contribué justement à la à cette
infrastructure par le budget de la
nation au développement des
infrastructures pour nous sncf réseau
est avant tout gestionnaire d'un
patrimoine qui est national et il n'est
pas lui le propriétaire de fait c'est
pourquoi nous vous invitons à voter
notre amendement
on m'a dit en commission qu'il était
satisfait mais je ne le crois pas tout
simplement parce que le la dette
s'appuie sur le réseau et le réseau et
voilà s'appuie sur la dette l'un est en
face de l'autre et donc tout est lié en
tout cas nous souhaitons nous réaffirmer
qu'il s'agit bien d'un bien nationale
qui appartient à tous les français
monsieur le rapporteur
effectivement nous avons
évoqué cet aspect lors de la réunion de
la commission du développement durable
et si nous avons bien compris l'esprit
de cet amendement il nous est apparu
qu'il était satisfait par l'amendement
que j'avais fait voter la semaine
d'avant lors de la première réunion de
la commission développement durable en
indiquant que sncf réseau et le
propriétaire unique de l'ensemble des
lignes du réseau ferré national sncf
réseau ethernet 500 publique de l'état
et c'est pas l'état qui gère directement
ce réseau c'est bien sncf réseau qui le
gère pour le compte de l'état donc pour
le compte de la nation donc dans ces
conditions il me semble que votre
amendement est satisfait par celui que
j'avais fait voter en commission
monsieur le ministre mais en effet
normalement qui avait été présentée par
monsieur le rapporteur est d'une clarté
limpide une efficacité remarquable et
donc je pense que la position et déjà
satisfaite par d'action et l'adoption de
l'amendement du rapporteur
maintenant le chercheur la parole vous
l'avez
oui monsieur le président nous ne sommes
pas en accord est ce que vient de dire
le ministre il y à confusion nous
voulons simplement dire est actée dans
ce beau projet de loi que la nation est
propriétaire c'est la propriété de la
nation et je crois que les français nous
diront merci après une concession pour
la gestion de cette infrastructure est
simplement ce que nous vous demandons
pour bien clarifier les choses monsieur
le ministre que ce soit acté ainsi dans
ce projet de loi je remercie
donc l'amendement est maintenue va donc
être mis aux voix qui est pour
contre
abstentions il n'est pas adoptée jamais
revoir l'article 2 qui est pour
contre
abstention l'article 2 est adopté
après l'article de l'amendement numéro
57 c'est toujours où madame church
oui monsieur le président par cet
amendement nous portons une idée simple
je dirais presque de prudence le
financement la construction la
transformation l'entretien la
maintenance l'exploitation la gestion
des ouvrages d'équipement de biens
immatériels nécessaire pour les
infrastructures de transport terrestre
nécessite à notre avis une maîtrise
publique et doivent être réalisés par le
groupe public ferroviaire c'est pourquoi
nous vous proposons
d'interdire les contrats de partenariat
public privé en matière
d'infrastructures de transport il s'agit
ainsi de tirer toutes les conséquences
de l'expérience du recours aux ppp trop
souvent bien plus coûteux pour la
collectivité les usagers est moins
performant en terme de service le
scandale du contrat aide et pau ecomouv
pardon pour ne citer que le dernier en
date d'une liste malheureusement très
longue démontre que cette forme de
contrat administrative véritable bombe à
retardement est un gouffre pour la
collectivité une faute politique morale
et financière ce qui est ailleurs et est
explicitée dans la mission de ecomouv je
pense mes chers collègues que cela n'est
plus à démontrer c'est pourquoi monsieur
le ministre au vu de votre volonté de
mieux maîtriser les dépenses engagées en
faveur du réseau je vous invite à tirer
les conséquences de ces expériences
coûteuse pour les deniers publics et à
voter cet amendement de prudence qui dit
qu'en effet il ne faut pas en passer par
là car c'est extrêmement coûteux pour la
collectivité
merci monsieur le rapporteur
de nombreux membres
de la commission développement durable
comprennent et partagent vos inquiétudes
sur la question du recours
aux contrats de partenariat et en
particulier aux ppp
toutefois il nous a semblé que cette
question dépasse largement le cadre
de la réforme ferroviaire dont nous
débattons actuellement c'est une
question beaucoup plus large et vous
avez d'ailleurs cité tout à l'heure un
exemple dont on a beaucoup parlé au
cours des derniers mois et que je ne
citerai pas à mon tour donc dans ces
conditions il me semble qu'il faut s'en
tenir au contenu du projet de loi de
réforme ferroviaire c'est d'ailleurs la
position qui a été prise par la
commission qui a émis un avis
défavorable pour cette raison là
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice on pouvait pas trouver en moi
un promoteur acharné des ppp les
partenariats public-privé j'emmenais
même abandonner un certain nombre pour
ne pas les citer le canal seine nord
le grand contournement de strasbourg
le cdg express
mais pour autant je n'ai abandonné aucun
projet puisque le canal seine nord est
en mission de reconfigurer à sion et
avec des avancées significatives
le grand contournement de strasbourg est
aussi en passe de
détermination de d'actualisation de la
dlp sauf erreur ou à une phase
procédural sur laquelle je peux revenir
le cdg express nous avons un parfum ppp
pour le coup mais qui est un partenariat
public public c'est donc non pas la
nécessité
d'interdire mais au contraire d'avoir la
responsabilité de bien gérer les
affaires lorsqu'on est aux
responsabilités
peut-être d'anticiper d'éventuels
retournements de situation économique ce
qui n'a pas été le cas
d'entourer les personnes publiques de
suffisamment de garanties dans les
clauses contractuelles
de ne pas avoir une vision dogmatique
pour le coup c'était comme vous qui a
été négocié dans les conditions que vous
savez tout à l'heure je ne vous ai pas
répondu sur la responsabilité qui est la
nôtre je n'ai pas répondu aux
missionnaires enfin quand même sur l'éco
taxe poids lourds permettez-moi en trois
minutes de revenir je ferai quand trois
minutes sur la responsabilité qui est la
vote de votre responsable de votre
majorité de ce qui a été décidé en 2007
pas appliquée en 2008 repoussé en 2009
signé en 2010 pas appliquée en 2011 et
signé le 6 mai 2012 c'est-à-dire date du
jour de l'élection présidentielle vous
sur mon bureau j'ai eu le décret que vos
collègues et amis politiques n'avaient
pas eu le courage d'appliquer et qui
avait mis le feu à toute la profession
alors je veux bien qu'après on soit un
peu outré en disant nous n'avons pas les
modalités de financement et settat et
cetera d'une loi qui a été votée à
l'unanimité à l'unanimité oui voté à
l'unanimité et combattue par vos amis
est combattu par vos amis lorsque nous
sommes passés devant le parlement ici
que vous avez dit que le gouvernement
céder comment une forme de pression
bottone enfin demandé à monsieur le fur
qui sauf erreur les adhérents d'aucun
des membres de des groupes de ce côté de
l'hémicycle donc il serait quand même
oui très grands spécialistes en effet
mais on peut parler parce que moi aussi
je suis grand spécialiste de la
nécessité de négocier et de financer les
infrastructures et un pays qui avance
c'est un pays qui doivent faire
confiance à une des modalités de
financement des infrastructures et ne
pas jouer de cela de ces enjeux
nationaux au nom de petits calculs
politiciens quitte à mettre le feu dans
nos régions donc chacun sera renvoyée à
ses responsabilités mais moi je
n'assumerai pas des responsabilités qui
sont pas les miennes et nous savons les
difficultés qui sont aujourd'hui face un
autre pays parce gouvernement
précisément au pays aux régions aux
territoires sur les difficultés de
financement des infrastructures
vous avez négocié un ppp ecomouv au
moment où l'état était dans une
situation où ils pouvaient assumer
pourquoi parce que en d'autres temps de
façon dogmatique vous avez décidé de
prix utilisez les autoroutes dans des
conditions scandaleuses que nous savons
on ne réforme en eau réservant qu'une
partie minimum des gains de cette
privatisation à lafitte la privant ainsi
des moyens de financement je suis
intarissable sur vos erreurs
intarissable sur ce qui est de votre
responsabilité parce que je suis
redevable de faire aboutir ce genre de
situation et la nécessité pour nos
territoires parce que toutes et tous
venez me voir légitimement nous avons
pour désenclaver pour moderniser pour
sécuriser et que nous avons y compris
dans le domaine routier 20 % du réseau
qui est extrêmement des ratés c'est
qu'une question de sécurité devant les
français et là aussi nous devons dire la
vérité donc vous voyez je reviens à la
situation il ne s'agit pas de nous
priver la mode de financement qui peut
être utile finalement qui peut être
utile à condition d'avoir le sens des
responsabilités de ne pas en faire une
arme idéologique de financement des
infrastructures et de toujours avoir
présent à l'esprit lorsqu'on est aux
responsabilités que le bien commun c'est
le bien de tous les français et
lorsqu'on agit au nom de l'état le poids
et le sens d'une signature publique
cette quelque chose qui engage tout le
monde et qui doit nous permettre de
préserver l'intérêt commun de l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens c'est ça le sens des
responsabilités voyez monsieur nez c'est
ce à quoi je vous renvoie merci monsieur
le ministre votre avis était assez large
est ce que j'ai bien compris si votre
avis est négatif sur 7 6 la rue parce
qu'ils ont de bons donc la vie est donc
négatif monsieur capot kader depuis
monsieur legs qui semble-t-il vous
voulez vous oui bien sûr présent
puisqu'on se méprenne pas quand je
disais monsieur le futur grand
spécialiste je le disais à la sude votre
expression sur la pression bretonne donc
effectivement spécialistes
parlementaires bretons aguerris et
légitimement spécialiste de la pression
bretonne monsieur le furent là c'était
pas ça n'était pas une spécialité que je
visais mais après tout c'est son rôle je
veux pas allongé les débats toutefois
ayant entendu tout à l'heure notre
excellent collègue madame recherche
appliquée le mot scandale au contrat et
comme ouf je voulais juste rappeler
votre séjour ensemble d'ailleurs que
dans la commission d' enquête
sur ecomouv on a eu des débats a certes
mais on on a abouti à des conclusions
qui était tout de même beaucoup plus
nuancée que le mot scandale voilà c'est
si on lit bien le rapport la commission
denquête on n'a pas trouvé de scandales
en tout cas c'est la lecture que j'en ai
eu je voulais juste en témoigner pour
que les choses soient claires sur ce
succès sur ce point là merci sa collègue
monsieur louis
monsieur le ministre jusque là ça allait
à peu près bien bon si vous perdez votre
sang froid je le regrette bon alors vous
me renvoyez à mes responsabilités je
vais vous renvoyer au vote à ce moment
là vous me parlez de le furent je vais
vous parler de le dryat je vous parlais
de lebranchu si vous me dites
effectivement que on n'a pas été
performants les uns et les autres ça
irait déjà un peu mieux mais évitons
s'il vous plaît dans le cadre de
l'intérêt général dont je sais que vous
y êtes sensibles le but de la démarche
c'est d'obtenir des crédits des moyens
pour faire en sorte que nos
infrastructures puisse fonctionner et
être maintenue à un bon niveau dans ces
conditions nous avons effectivement
soutenu par exemple laffitte nous avons
fait en sorte que justement vous qui
aviez suspendu parce que c'est vous qui
avez suspendu nous on a signé de très
tardivement nous on attend maintenant
nous on a signé très tardivement vous
vous avez suspendu donc à bord voilà et
puis finalement quand même quand vous
parlez de la dette de villepin je crois
que c'était le premier ministre de
l'époque mais voilà mais qu'est ce qu'il
a fait qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a
récupéré cet argent pour combler pour
combler une dette de l'état et donc lui
au moins il avait anticipé par rapport à
aujourd'hui où vous me renvoyez au
traitement de la dette
à mon avis ce débat peut continuer
monsieur mais si vous lui pour
poursuivre c'est votre droit
nous assistons à un aveu un aveu cet
heureux que ce débat en marge grâce à
votre intervention les masques tombent
puisque vous venait d'avouer en effet
que vous étiez prêts à sacrifier les
modalités de financement des
infrastructures en prenant en exemple
vous êtes bien le seul l'action qui a
été celle de monsieur villepin tant qu
en tant que promu ministre de la
privatisation en fait de bradage de ce
qui est le patrimoine commun l'homme
vous venez de l'assumer vous venez de le
dire de dire au moins monsieur villepin
lui a eu raison de privatiser alors même
que les parlementaires ont eu à mener
une mission d'information sur ces
conditions de privatisation des
autoroutes que l'eau jour d'hui nous
sommes ligoté par des contrats qui ont
été mal négociées au détriment de
l'intérêt de la nation de l'état et qui
nous empêchent aujourd'hui de pouvoir
disposer du domaine public qui est géré
dans les conditions que nous savons et
qui m'a fallu me battre pendant deux ans
pour obtenir ne serait-ce que
l'actualisation que vous n'aviez pas
fait de la redevance domaniale c'est à
dire le fait de pouvoir faire payer un
juste prix ce qui est l'utilisation du
domaine public voilà comment vous aviez
des relations qui étaient des relations
comment puis je les qualifiées
d'indulgentes par rapport à ceux
auxquels il avait été donné mission de
gérer le bien de la nation eh bien nous
nous sommes non pas dans une forme
d'indulgence mais nous sommes dans
l'exigence je le démontre depuis deux
ans et ça n'est pas fini
merci madame charge
oui merci monsieur le président donc en
effet je pense que les responsabilités
quand même reviennent à la droite et
pour premièrement ce dossier ecomouv
nous avons été bien seul au tout début à
dire qu'il était complètement
défavorable aux finances de l'état ça
s'est avéré positif lors de notre
mission quand même commune d'information
je n'ai pas voté la dernière conclusion
parce que excusez moi contrat
exceptionnel non il n'est pas
exceptionnel il est complètement
scandaleux franchement et là on le sait
tous maintenant on a eu les comptes
devant nous il s'agissait de 250
millions d'euros par an franchement
c'était complètement excessif je veux
dire aussi à monsieur le ministre que
comme nous avons subi la rgpp il est
vrai que lorsqu'on avait
ça c'est apparu lors du contrat ecomouv
nos services de l'état nos grandes
directions des services de l'état n'ont
pas été sans doute suffisamment
conforter pour donner les bons conseils
à des ministres ou un président qui peut
être aussi ne le souhaitez pas trop
c'est à dire ils ont quand même laissé
filer les choses je veux pas accuser les
grands services de l'état mais je quand
même dire que la rgpp a déshabillé nos
grands services et c'est regrettable et
qu'il faut y veiller je vais retirer mon
amendement monsieur le ministre parce
que je pense qu en effet il ya un vrai
étape danger dans les contrats
partenariat ppp et je voulais le dire
fortement ici au regard de notre de nos
expériences passées vous allez vous avez
dit d'autres exemples vous même que vous
avez dû renégocier et je pense que
nombreux ici or il y a quelques années
passées nous n'entendions que ppp dans
cet hémicycle donc voilà le temps a
changé j'en suis heureux si vous voulez
et je voulais acté ce fait là et je vais
donc retirer cet amendement parce que je
vais pas non plus paraître extrêmement
dogmatique si par hasard un pb bien
encadré 1 à condition qu'ils le soient
vraiment bien et que ce soit pour la
collectivité publique tellement nous
sommes attachés aux investissements dans
nos infrastructures ferroviaires voilà
monsieur le président bien néanmoins je
mets votre amendement 57 il retirait
pour retirer
le 58 c'est toujours c'est madame didier
qui présente
madame didier monsieur le président mes
chers collègues
nous proposons la suppression de cet
article si vous le voulez bien je vais
faire aussi la défense de l'amendement
suivant
par cet amendement nous demandons
purement et simplement la suppression de
cet article nouveau adopté lors du débat
de l'assemblée nationale nous
demanderons d'ailleurs également la
suppression du prochain article pour des
raisons identiques je ferai donc défense
commune je viens de le dire cet article
ouvre en effet la possibilité aux
régions de racheter certaines petites
lignes d'intérêts purement locales afin
de peindre les laisser se détériorer le
l'objet et est important bien entendu si
nous ne contestons pas les intentions
mentionnés par les auteurs de cet
amendement qui évoque quasiment des
situations d'exception on l'a entendu ce
matin nous restons dubitatifs sur
l'orientation de ces amendements en lien
avec l'acte iii de la décentralisation
et le renforcement du rôle des régions
détriment de l'état ces articles
permettent ainsi aux régions de racheter
des lignes ou bien d'en créer tout
d'abord nous nous interrogeons comment
le pourront-elles et avec quels moyens
alors même que les dotations dont elle
bénéficie en font baisser nous estimons
plus fondamentalement que par ces
articles nous mettons le doigt dans un
mécanisme qui n'est pas le bon ouvrant
la possibilité de régionalisation de la
gestion des infrastructures déjà prévu
donc dans les esquisses de l'acte iii de
la décentralisation
certes on nous dit aujourd'hui qu'il ne
s'agit pas du tout du réseau ferré
national mais ce que vous ne dites pas
c'est que le périmètre du réseau
national peut bien évidemment évolué on
ne précise pas les choses ce qui est
national aujourd'hui peut devenir
régional demain nous trouvons donc ces
articles dangereux dans leurs esprits
puisqu'il reconnaît sans aucun
encadrement spécifique une compétence
pleine et entière aux régions pour
devenir gestionnaire d'infrastructure en
lieu et place du gestionnaire national
créé par la présente loi sncf réseau
nous estimons par conséquent ce que ces
articles loin de permettre le retour de
l'état stratège ouvre la voie à une
régionalisation permettant une
application inégalitaire sur le
territoire du droit à la mobilité de
plus au regard des objectifs de
rentabilité a signé à sncf réseau il est
bien clair qu'il sera fort opportun pour
elle comptablement parlant de se
départir d'une partie du réseau sur les
régions pour toutes ces raisons et sans
dénier les motivations certainement
légitime des auteurs de ces amendements
à l'assemblée
et ici d'ailleurs nous souhaitons que le
message de ce projet de loi ne soit pas
brouillé par des informations
contradictoires ce projet doit permettre
le retour de l'état stratège la
réunification de la famille ferroviaire
pour la rendre plus forte il ne doit pas
engagé l'atomisation du réseau et la
multiplication des gestionnaires
d'infrastructures c'est pour ces raisons
que nous vous proposons la suppression
de deux de ses articles merci madame
didier mais cette instance
d'abord un commentaire sur l'amendement
effectivement l'article 2 bis ça
permet aux régions de racheter certaines
petites lignes d'intérêts purement
locale il est donc nullement question
de remettre en cause l'unicité du réseau
national unis cité qui a fait ses
preuves et qui constitue
incontestablement le support de l'état
stratège il s'agit en l'occurrence de
permettre le rachat de petits ligne à
voie métrique c'est à dire des voies
ferrées d'un écartement d'un mètre et
qui ne sont ils sont donc séparés
physiquement du réseau ferré national
donc dans ces conditions il n'y a pas
d'atteinte à l'unicité du réseau ferré
national s'agissant du 59 qui a été
présentée aussi en même temps me
semble-t-il
donc avis défavorable sur le premier
avis défavorable également sur le second
puisque là c'est l'article 2 bis b qui
permet aux régions de créaude exploiter
des lignes d'intérêt régional et c'est
une demande forte des régions elle
permettra si elle est votée de régler
certains cas ponctuels et tout le monde
pense évidemment à la ligne nice digne
de manière à permettre à la région paca
de devenir ce qu'elle n'est pas
gestionnaire de plein de pleine
compétence de la ligne par ailleurs
cette compétence d'une manière générale
reste optionnel et bien évidemment les
régions qu'ils souhaitent
seul ancien dans la gestion
d'infrastructures pourront le faire
ainsi mais sncf réseau restera bien
compétent pour créer et exploiter les
lignes du réseau ferré national donc
deux avis défavorables pour les raisons
que je viens de rappeler deux avis
défavorables de la commission
merci monsieur ministre
merci monsieur le président l'adage
populaire veut que tout ce qui est petit
est mignon j'ignore si là il s'agit
d'être dans ce domaine de référence mais
je sais que ce qui est des petits
réseaux nécessitent des modes de gestion
qui peuvent être adaptés en l'occurrence
il s'agit pas ce sont des précautions
que vous souhaitez certainement
appelés par votre amendement
d'interpellations il s'agit pas d'un
démantèlement du réseau il s'agit très
clairement comme l'a dit monsieur le
rapporteur de petits segments clairement
identifiés qui se trouve être
séparés physiquement du reste du réseau
j'ai la liste nice digne blanc en charge
blanc argent le train jaune le fameux
train jaune le mont blanc express près
et vous avez le midi pour ceux qui ont
la chance de regarder ce qui n'est pas
notre cas mais je sais qu'il ya de très
très beaux reportages sur les trains
touristiques qui nous occupait ce matin
chère madame la ministre sur également
les opérateurs sur france 2 chaque midi
vous avez là de véritable saga de ceux
qui passionnés ont besoin de faire vivre
aussi ce patrimoine vivant ferroviaire
et qui nécessite d'avoir des règles de
s'adapter et qu'il s'agisse là de 7
cet amendement qui est de cette
disposition qui a été votée à
l'initiative d'un certain nombre de
groupes de l'assemblée nationale ou
qu'il s'agisse des trains touristiques
ou qu'il s'agisse des opérateurs
ferroviaires de proximité il est de la
même logique de pouvoir adapter pour des
situations particulières pour des
petites entités ou pour des réseaux
capillaires qui peuvent avoir des effets
de démultiplication économique mais avec
un portage d'opérateur ou
d'investissements publics adaptés tour
de table qui peuvent amener à ce que les
régions où d'autres collectifs et et
interviennent je pense notamment et je
faisais référence à ce qui est du réseau
ferré portuaire par exemple oui il y à
un certain nombre de situations qui sans
remettre en cause l'unicité sans
craindre
l'atomisation du réseau peut permettre
d'avoir une efficacité ferroviaire et de
répondre à des situations d'espèces
voilà donc je donnerai un avis
défavorable vous n'en serais pas
surprise
monsieur
cet article 2 bis à il faut le même
tenir
il faut le maintenir pourquoi parce que
on est tous d'accord sur tout ses bas
pour avoir un réseau structurant
national auquel on ne touche pas on est
tous d'accord là dessus par contre là où
je suis favorable c'est qu'on assure une
certaine souplesse au système pour
justement atteindre l'objectif qui est
encore une fois un objectif où on met
l'usagé et le service au centre de la
démarche tout à l'heure et le rapporteur
on a fait une très bonne démonstration
par exemple sur nice digne si la région
n'étaient pas intervenues je peux vous
dire que aujourd'hui la ligne ne
fonctionnerait plus donc soyons
réalistes regardons ce qui fonctionne et
n'ayant pas de position idéologique ou
sectaires
terminerait pour répondre à monsieur le
ministre tout à l'heure et qui avait une
charge excessive qui lui ressemble
absolument pas d'un homme est en état d
où la télé on ne cherche mon trop bon et
donc monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre vous auriez été bien inspiré
plutôt que d'attaquer un peu violemment
de garder votre sang froid 1 2 2 des
femmes puisque vous représentez le
gouvernement et l'état à charge et à
décharge tout ce que j'ai dit moi c'est
non pas que j'étais ville père j'ai
jamais dit ça j'étais même pas élu à
l'époque c'est dire mais je reprenais la
version officielle qui avaient été
donnés tout simplement
ne mettez pas le président de séance en
difficulté merci bien et
je vais bientôt voir cet amendement 50
et madame didier demande la parole
merci monsieur le président tout d'abord
je voudrais indiquer que quand on parle
de réseau national encore faut-il
définir ce qu'il est et jusqu'ici nous
n'avons pas eu des définitions qui nous
ont vraiment satisfait on parle de nice
digne très bien mais c'est un cas
particulier et on sait très bien que les
cas particuliers si on met un texte de
loi qui prévoit les choses ça va ça va
pouvoir s'appliquer à plein d'autres
situations donc là encore on n'a pas
précisé les choses quand notre
rapporteur qui parle des voies métriques
nous savons ce que sont les voies
métriques la plupart du temps elles sont
sur les emprises industrielles elles
sont effectivement sur des petites
lignes ferroviaires elles ne sont pas
branchés au réseau national par principe
on est bien d'accord donc que celle ci
trouve un règlement particulier mais
qu'on le dise dans la loi qu'on dise que
c'est le ce sont les voies métriques qui
sont mises en dehors du réseau et ça
nous semblera facile mais vraiment nous
souffrons l'a2 d'un manque de définition
au fond de clarification nous savons
pertinemment qu'un texte comme celui-là
permettra ensuite d'ouvrir à d'autres
possibilités
quand opposition idéologique et sectaire
chers collègues vous savez nous vous
savons grand spécialiste du chemin de
fer mais on n'est pas non plus sans
connaissance sur le sujet
merci chers collègues je vais mettre
voir cet abonnement cinquante huit pieds
pour
compte
abstention il n'est pas adoptée je me
vois l'article 2 bis à
un homme cherche sur cet article sur
pour l'autre moment je mets donc on voit
l'article 2 bis à pour
contre abstentions l'article est adopté
et donc ensuite tendons à l'amendement
qui était défendu 59 et
nous avons eu l'avis de la commission du
gouvernement pour explication de vote
madame charge monsieur le président
l'article 2 bis b donc c'est bien ce
dont nous discutons il est bien
explicite et sans préjudice des
dispositions rapides premier les régions
sont compétentes pour créer ou exploiter
des infrastructures de transport ferré
ou guidées intérêt régional donc là
monsieur le ministre avouez que nous
nous envoyons un message extrêmement
brouillée parce qu'en effet on commence
à écrire que les régions peuvent créer
et exploiter des infrastructures ce que
nous regrettons dans ce projet de loi où
vous faites fort le champion de
l'unicité d'un réseau
merci donc l'avis de la commission est
exprimé l'avis du gouvernement exprimé
je vais mettre voir
qu'est pour
compte
abstention il n'est pas adopté
l'article 160 l'amendement 160 étaient
déplacés je vais souvent à l'article 2
bis b pour
contre abstention adopté l'amendement
monsieur le ministre amendement du
gouvernement
vais-je inquiétait madame usher je ne
voudrais pas puisque vous reconnaissez
en moi comment avez-vous dit le champion
de l'unicité
ouais en effet c'est une forme d'hommage
d'autant plus que c'est vous qui
prononçait ses propos et ses mots
cet amendement présenté devant vous pour
la première fois devant la haute
assemblée
par le gouvernement est un amendement
qui vise à promouvoir le développement
les dessertes portuaires ferroviaires je
l'évoqué peut-être rapidement ce matin
mais c'est un enjeu qui est un enjeu
majeur d'abord parce qu'il s'inscrit
dans la stratégie de relance portuaires
que j'avais présenté à rouen et au havre
il ya plus d'un an et qui doit permettre
d'optimiser
les infrastructures faisant l'interface
entre la terre et la mer le mettons de
bénéficier de ce que représentent les
ports et notamment les 360 millions de
tonnes de fret or force est de constater
que des réseaux et parfois des réseaux
existants d'ailleurs les réseaux
existants sur deux domaines le portuaire
sont souvent ils utilisés voire mal
utilisé d'abord parce qu'il ya une
réalité la confusion parfois la
difficulté
l'efficacité économique insuffisamment
exploré des
l'ensemble de ses espaces ferroviaire la
confusion des rôles des gens des
missions de sorte que même ceux qui ont
responsabilité de ces réseaux
ferroviaires n'ont pas conscience et
donc nous engage pas le travail
nécessaire pour essayer d'obtenir une
rayonnement et un bénéfice de ses 360
millions de tonnes de marchandises qui
continuent à être acheminés par la route
le plus souvent lors l'idée n'est pas là
encore remettre en cause moi qui suis
champion de l'unicité du réseau cette
réalité du réseau mais au contraire de
faire en sorte que nous puissions et que
les territoires et notamment les ports
puis se tirer plein profit de ses
infrastructures existantes de donner les
moyens d'avoir une gouvernance adaptée
d'avoir aussi le bénéfice de la
sensibilisation de ses gestions faire en
sorte que comme c'est le cas pour les
grands ports nationaux y compris les
ports décentralisés puisse avoir pleine
conscience de ce que représente comme
potentiel l'existence de ces réseaux
ferré portuaire et d'ailleurs j'ai
confié et vous le savez à votre collègue
sénatrice madame hervio
rapport sur les ports décentralisés leur
gouvernance un très bon rapport
d'ailleurs qui ne manquera pas de
pouvoir clarifier dans le cadre de la
réforme territoriale ou pas d'ailleurs
de pouvoir impulser clarifier la
gouvernance des ports décentralisés et
dans ses rapports il y à aussi l'accent
est mis sur cette question du dynamisme
des logiques de façade maritime et du
bénéfice que nous pouvons tirer que nous
devons tirer de ces infrastructures
insuffisamment utilisées aussi il vous
est proposé par cet amendement de
pouvoir inciter et faire en sorte que
possibilités soit donnée à tous les
ports de devenir propriétaire des
infrastructures ferroviaires dans un
périmètre qui est clairement identifié
de toute façon la benne domanialité
publique maritime ou portuaire doit nous
permettre de pouvoir clarifier
l'ensemble de l'espace concerné est de
pouvoir développer un modèle économique
et commerciale adaptée aux besoins à la
relance portuaire et bien sûr à ce que
nous pouvons apporter comme
concrétisation à un report modal
intelligent
merci chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
et vous y avez fait religieux
cet amendement
répond à une des recommandations
formulées par notre collègue d'interview
dans son rapport sur les enjeux les
perspectives de la décentration
portuaire j'ai sous les yeux une des
recommandations et en particulier celle
qui est au coeur du débat que nous avons
à l'instant sur votre amendement elle
indique qu'il faut finaliser entre rff
et les autorités portuaires les
conventions de transfert des équipements
ferroviaires pour permettre au port de
mener une politique ambitieuse de
développement de l'activité ferroviaire
en fonction du trafic portuaire c'est la
raison pour laquelle notre commission a
été sensible à cette argumentation et
qu'elle a émis un avis favorable sur
votre amendement
merci bien monsieur explications
de vote
une fois n'est pas coutume je suis très
favorable à cet amendement du
gouvernement pourquoi parce que parce
que parce qu'il s'inscrit totalement
dans les conclusions de mobilité 21 de
la commission mobilité 21 dans lequel on
s'est aperçu que nous avions des ports
nous avions des lignes de chemin de fer
et y manquer l'interface est donc à ce
moment là le fait de pouvoir utiliser
ces lignes torturées qui sont sous
utilisées aujourd'hui permettra de
dynamiser nos ports est bien entendu
faudra augmenter le fret
merci bien pas d'autres explications de
vote chaque collègue non j'ai cru pardon
je vais tout voir c'est à mon sens soit
9 qui pour
contre
abstentions
il est adopté article 2 bis amendement
numéro douze présentés par monsieur
cet amendement
anticipe l'application au 1er janvier
2018 de la proposition de modification
de la directive 2012 34 de commission
européenne qui obligerait les états
membres à supprimer toute disposition
visant à limiter le droit d'accès au
marché domestique à une entreprise
ferroviaire je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui
les services ferroviaires nationaux de
voyageurs sont sous le monopole de la
sncf en référence à deux articles du
code des transports l'article l 21 41
1-1 qui précise que l'établissement
public industriel et commercial dénommé
sncf a pour objet d' exploiter selon les
principes du service public les services
de transport ferroviaire de personnes
sur le réseau national et l'article l 21
21-12 qui distingue comme service
librement organisé sur le marché
les entreprises ferroviaires exploitant
des services de transport international
de voyageurs cet article qui n'autorise
le libre droit d'accès aux gares que
pour les services internationaux de
voyageurs traduit indirectement une
limitation du droit d'accès en gare en
france au service librement organisé et
par conséquent traduit à son tour un
monopole de la sncf
donc nous souhaitons que les entreprises
ferroviaires exploitant des services de
transport de voyageurs puissent assurer
des dessertes intérieures
merci chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur
en 12 amendements numéro 12 déposée par
notre collègue louis lui l'aigre
on reconnaît bien là sa constance dans
l'effort
il dit dans l'anticipation
dans l'effort mais je ne suis pas
certain du tout qu'ils soient achevées
table d'anticiper pourquoi parce que
l'ouverture à la concurrence de tous les
services de transports de rigeur si elle
intervient
n'interviendra pas avant plusieurs
années et aujourd'hui nous débattons
comme hier d'un projet de loi de réforme
du système ferroviaire un projet de loi
qui vise à le renforcer pour le préparer
à la concurrence si cette concurrence
effectivement est réel dans quelques
années donc j'ai tendance à dire un
vinaigre n'anticipons pas
traitons aujourd'hui les questions qui
nous sont soumises
ce texte un pas pour objet d'anticiper
les prochaines échéances en matière
d'ouverture la concurrence vous
comprendrez donc moins chers collègues
que la commission devant durable et émis
un avis défavorable sur cet amendement
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur
est à nouveau repris par ses
obsessions
7 cette forme d'obsession maladive vous
est obnubilé par cette nécessaire
ce modèle unique cette mise en
concurrence elle vous en avais même
oublié le coeur même de ce projet de loi
qui est le fait de mettre en place un
service un groupe unifié ferroviaire
efficace un cadre social harmonisé de
pouvoir régler les missions de service
public de répondre à ce qu'attendent les
usagers et qu'attendent-ils opale
nécessairement ce que vous essayez comme
vous dites d'anticiper en fait vous
d'anticiper rien vous baisser pavillon
mais ils attendent de la sécurité ils
attendent de la qualité attendue confort
de la régularité voilà la réalité et
l'état dans lequel nous avons trouvé les
réseau ferroviaire amène à ce que nous
ayons à concentrer nos efforts sur ce
qui est l'essentiel il sera temps une
fois que nous aurons déterminé c'est
notre méthode là où vous avez bradé le
fret ferroviaire en anticipant une mise
à la concurrence nous nous souhaitons
renforcer le service public renforcé
l'opérateur public avoir des règles
claires stable égales pour les uns et
pour les autres il n'y a aucune
malédiction sur le service public qui
devrait faire que s'abat sur lui des
règles que ces votes défavorables qui
serait plus l'autre qui le ferait perdre
en compétitivité laissant la place aux
acteurs privés pour pouvoir bénéficier
de la loi du marché et donc faire
s'effondrer les opérateurs historiques
mais quand vous êtes vous dit que vous
anticipez je confirme que vous battez
pavillon parce que ce que nous
souhaitons faire au niveau de la
commission européenne cela fait plus de
deux ans là où vous ne vous étiez pas
battu c'est de faire triompher la
volonté de la france la singularité de
la france qui a été d'ailleurs retrouve
retrouvé par d'autres partenaires qui
ont permis de gagner sur la
compréhension et également sur la
position de la commission européenne qui
est aujourd'hui non seulement se rend
compte d'un calendrier trop restreint
est trop étriqué qui fait que nous
n'avons pas il n'est pas souhaitable
pour le ferroviaire d'imposer des dates
qu'il ne serait pas soutenable sauf à
désorganiser l'ensemble du ferroviaire
européen mais bien d'avoir des étapes un
calendrier il n'est pas figé là où vous
souhaitez l'anticiper comme d'autres
d'ailleurs moi j'ai souhaité solidifier
le dispositif et faire en sorte que
lorsque la date sera précisée
elle doit être lointaine elle doit être
reculé parce que nous ne sommes pas en
situation aujourd'hui d'avoir un
opérateur qui puisse subir une mise en
concurrence qui ne serait pas équilibré
voilà la réalité
envoyez nationale
vous avez eu la démonstration
alors vous allez me dire mais je n'étais
pas élu je ne suis pas redevables ce
qu'on fait de mal mais prédécesseur des
amis vous avez eu quand même la mise en
concurrence du fret ferroviaire vous
avez vu par quelle démonstration le fait
de ne pas avoir préparé l'opérateur
historique a mené à l'effondrement nos
parts le gain sous prétexte d'ouverture
à différents acteurs du ferroviaire et
du frais de ferrol dans le fret
ferroviaire nous aurions pu penser c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui nous avait été prédit
que l'ouverture à d'autres opérateurs
permettrait de pouvoir dynamiser il ya
même eu des déclarations des
statistiques des chiffres qui ont été
annoncés dans le grenelle de
l'environnement aucun ont été tenus le
fait d'ouvrir à d'autres opérateurs n'a
pas eu pour effet loin s'en faut ce même
linverse d'augmenter la part modale du
ferroviaire du fret ferroviaire mais
bien de déstabiliser l'opérateur
historique sncf fret et aujourd'hui nous
voyons combien la me manque de
préparation le manque d'anticipation sur
la le caractère solide des règles
applicables et bien à amener à une
fragilité qui est dommageable lorsqu'il
s'agit de l'opérateur qui est un élément
du patrimoine ferroviaire comme un
merci monsieur le ministre vous ne serez
pas surpris que monsieur demande
la parole est il là
monsieur le ministre
vous avez dit que j'étais atteint par
une maladie je vous renvoie la pièce
nous ne sommes pas atteints par la même
maladie en l'occurrence vous vous êtes
atteint par le syndrome de la ligne
maginot bon on se replie en france on se
recroqueville et on attend qu'on soit
attaquée on n'anticipe pas le rapporteur
l'a dit vous l'avez confirmé c'est pas
comme ça c'est pas comme ça qu'on gagne
les batailles je pense que et vous
l'avez confirmé d'ailleurs vous l'avez
confirmer parce que dans votre
argumentaire est un petit truc qui colle
pas bien là vous avez dit que
l'entreprise nationale la sncf n'est pas
un état de combattre alors que depuis 91
depuis 91 on sait qu'on doit ouvrir à la
concurrence
et bien ce qu'on fait en france et qu'on
recule devant l'obstacle c'est qu'à ce
moment là on baisse pas lyon ça c'est
vrai c'est au ministre la mère que je
dis ça moi aussi et donc à partir de là
on est plus à même de gagner de
conquérir comme vous voulez c'est quand
vous laissez la sncf
béret d'un vous avez des résultats
regardez la sncf libérer sept sncf
libéré commequiers des parts de marché
par les pays étrangers et notamment en
angleterre fait donc de même en france
si vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président écoutez mon
cher collègue louis avant de mener
cette bataille il faut mettre l'armée en
ordre c'est ce que c'est ce que nous
faisons actuellement un recentrer les
forces sur la sncf avant d'affronter
cette période je rappelle après
l'ouverture à la concurrence du fret du
transport international de voyageurs cet
amendement propose d'ouvrir avec
anticipation à la concurrence du
transport national de voyageurs nous
savons tous ici que l'ouverture à la
concurrence peut arriver elle arrivera
un jour où l'autre qu'elle est engagée
depuis 2000 au niveau européen la
directive de 1200 de 2012 34 que vous
connaissez qui a pour objet l'ouverture
à la concurrence a été examiné par les
députés européens en avril dernier pour
l'instant le processus législatif
européen est loin d'être arrivé à son
terme bon on le sait tout ça alors
pourquoi vouloir anticiper une ouverture
la concurrence dont les modalités ne
sont pas encore définitivement établi la
question de l'ouverture à la concurrence
n'est pas à sa place dans le débat
d'aujourd'hui
je le crois
c'est ce texte envisage les évolutions
dans le bon ordre il s'agit dans ce
débat de faire un choix industriel
important de corriger les
dysfonctionnements créé par la loi de
1997 laquelle vous tenez tant
malheureusement de stabiliser une
trajectoire financière qui
malheureusement part à la dérive il
s'agit ici de mettre en place un groupe
public
ferroviaire fort de conserver toutes les
compétences de la sncf bref de créer un
acteur puissant qui exercera des
missions de services publics et
d'aménagement du territoire pour aborder
comme je le disais en préambule le
moment qui viendra peut-être en 2019
2023 voilà je pense que la tâche
d'aujourd'hui suffit à notre open merci
chers collègues je vais mettre au point
cet amendement numéro 12 qui est pour
contre
abstentions il n'est pas adopté un
amendement 96 rectifié monsieur
capo-canellas ce
merci monsieur le président je viens
tout de suite sur le 96 rectifie juste
autoriserait une toute petite digression
parce qu'il se trouve que en venant ce
matin je me suis demandé si la sncf mais
on voulait parce que le rer b a eu un
important retard c'était ça n'étonne pas
roger que je rends tant que l'entente
réagi et en lui était promis de pas vous
le dire parce que si on va quand même
pas trouvé les débats avec des éléments
qui sont après tout personnel et donc ce
matin j'ai cru raté les et premier
amendement parce que ça ne démarrait pas
il y avait un problème de signalisation
en gare du nord et il y avait un malaise
voyageurs en gare de la courneuve bon
mais tout ça pas mal retardé et puis
finalement je me résous à vous en parler
parce qu'il se trouve que rff m'en veux
aussi je vais recevoir pas mal d'appels
parce que il ya chez moi au bourget la
chute d'un pont qui est en construction
enfin en rénovation et la tangentielle
nord qui a juste deux ans et demi trois
ans de retard aux gels c est ce pont
fait que les gravats enfin le ballast
tombent sur la chaussée donc on est en
train de fermer une route départementale
wap alors comme je sais que les
responsables de ces belles institutions
sncf rff suivent forcément les débats en
direct parce qu'ils sont professionnels
s'ils peuvent agir chez moi au bourget
sur la voilà voilà je pense que ça ira
plus vite pour réparer ces travaux voilà
mais enfin c'est le sort qui s'acharne
bien j'avais dit plus sérieusement je
reviens à l'abondant 96 qui
effectivement un amendement je pense
qu'il peut être utile en tout cas que je
soumets la sagacité de la haute
assemblée du rapporteur et du
gouvernement
il concerne donc sur l'article 2 bis on
sait que cette antique avec deux listes
la mise en conformité de la procédure de
vérification de l'objet principal du
service en matière de cabotage avec la
directive 2012 34 en la confiant
exclusivement à la raf voilà j'y reviens
selon le décret du 24 août 2010 le
ministre chargé des transports dispose
d'un délai d'un mois à compter la
réception de l'avis motivé de la raf sur
l'objet international du service
ferroviaire envisagée
et sur l'impact de ce nouveau service
sur l'équilibré économique d'un contrat
de service public pour prononcer la
limitation des dessertes intérieures
donc ce il ya un délai d'un mois
l'autorisation finale d'accorder une
entreprise ferroviaire la possibilité de
faire du cabotage intérieur revient donc
au ministère des transports qui est un
mois en supprimant l'opportunité pour
l'autorité administrative compétente
encadrer l'exercice de ses dessertes
intérieures dans la loi le mot gay
homologation ministérielle prévue par le
décret susvisé sera obligatoirement
supprimés suite à l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi portant réforme ferroviaire il
est proposé de fixer notamment le délai
de prise de décision à six semaines au
lieu d'un mois
après la fin de l'instruction de la
saisine conformément à la directive 2012
34e
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur
la commission diabang durable à a
considéré que cet amendement compléter
utilement le dispositif prévu à
l'article 12 bis elle a donc émis un
avis favorable
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président j'aimerais
peut-être
ce capot canelas
préciser puisque vous l'avez une
succession de forme de malédiction avec
la sncf et rff
mais penser qu' il s'agit pas là de
difficultés liées à ces deux opérateurs
ce que je me souviens que il ya quelques
mois vous deviez venir intervenir lors
d'un débat parlementaire et vous preniez
à l'époque
motos taxis et que vous étiez arrivé
très en retard puisque il y avait eu un
problème mécanique je crois et je pense
que vous avez et c'est important que
vous impliquer dans les débats
parlementaires sur les transports parce
que vous avez une relation aux
transports qui est très compliqué et qui
ne se limite pas à la sncf et rff
donc vos expériences nous sont
précieuses et d'important que vous
puissiez en effet sensibiliser tous les
acteurs qui ne se limite pas aux seuls
acteurs publics malheureusement pour
vous
alors puisqu'il s'agit de la raf
monsieur
puisqu'il s'agit de l'arast ça ne
m'étonne pas que cet amendement viennent
de vous lorsqu'il s'agit de la raf et
sur cette nécessité d'encadrer les
délais d'instruction je tiens à
souligner que nous sommes sensibles à
votre interpellation
sur cet amendement qui permet là aussi
d'être dans l'efficacité des procédures
donc nous y donnerons et réserveront un
avis favorable
j'espère que vous serez sensible ce que
le gouvernement retient de votre
contribution et que cet avis favorable
successives donner à vos contributions
pourront laisser présager un vote
favorable sur un texte qui est important
vous avez souligné combien il fallait
que nous nous mobilisions tous pour
améliorer les infrastructures de
transport ferroviaire à l'instant par
des anecdotes qui sont précieuses et
bien vous avez là votre responsabilité
qui sera engagée y compris sur le vote
de ce texte
merci je vais mettre voir cet amendement
96 rectifié qui est pour
contre
abstentions il est adopté l'article 2
bis je vais le mettre aux voix pour
contre abstentions il est adopté sur
l'article de terre une discussion
commune commence par l'amendement numéro
61 de madame cherche
oui monsieur le président l'article de
terre insère dans le projet de loi par
l'assemblée c'est réparé le projet de
loi par l'assemblée nationale prévoit la
remise au parlement d'un rapport du
gouvernement sur les solutions
permettant de traiter l'évolution de la
dette historique du système ferroviaire
ce rapport devra être remis dans un
délai de deux ans à compter de la
promulgation de la loi aux commissions
permanent du parlement compétentes en
matière ferroviaire et financière en
commission du développement durable à
l'initiative de notre rapporteur un
amendement a été adopté pour inclure
expressément dans le rapport prévu
l'examen d'une reprise de tout ou partie
de la dette du système ferroviaire par
l'état le rapport présente des données
intéressantes à cette occasion qui
confort les amendements que nous avons
défendu sans succès à l'article 2 est en
effet comme vous le notez monsieur le
rapporteur la cour des comptes a
souligné à plusieurs reprises je la cite
le caractère artificiel du portage par
rff d'une dette qu'il ne peut pas
amortir qui ne peut l'être que par
l'état ou et dont la nature est donc
quasi régaliennes vous poursuivez en
indiquant qu'une reprise partielle de la
dette par l'état permettrait à sncf
réseau de dégager des ressources
aujourd'hui affectée au financement de
sa dette pour l'entretien et la
régénération du réseau tout cela nous le
partageons c'est pourquoi nous proposons
que le rapport soit remis plus tôt dans
un délai de six mois et que des pistes
précises soit de plus analysé comme
l'opportunité et les modalités de
création d'une structure d'amortissement
de la dette ferroviaire la création
d'une structure ad-hoc où loger la dette
du système ferroviaire à l'image de ce
qu'a fait l'état allemand pour la dette
de la deutsche bahn ou l'état français
pour la dette de la sécurité sociale
confié à la kadey ce pourrait donc être
une piste voilà le sens de cet
amendement monsieur le président merci
beaucoup et me cherche l'amendement 91
monsieur capo canellas oui monsieur le
président merci d'abord monsieur le
ministre des mots qui a bien voulu avoir
c'est vrai que parfois un peu de
malchance dans les transports c'est vrai
que certains certaines y c'est un petit
peu compliqué mais je crois que tout le
monde est à l'oeuvre pour que ça
s'améliore je me réjouis d'être
dans la même ligne que notre collègue
madame recherche avec un amendement qui
est un tout petit peu moins large mais
qui a pour une large part le même objet
c'est à dire de faire que ce ce rapport
soit produit sous six mois sur le sur le
fond je ne vais pas vous rappeler
l'intérêt du sujet la question de la
dette ça a été rappelé les perspectives
qui doivent être rasées selon nous
rapidement sur ce sujet en particulier
merci chers collègues l'amendement
suivant 152
me suis catalan merci monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues bon bah là on exactement
dans la même lignée sur l'idée de
l'avancement du rapport mais mon
collègue capo-canellas est un peu moins
large que madame cherche ma collègue
cherche et nous autres écologistes dans
un souci de discussions et de compromis
on est un peu moins radicaux que lui dit
on pense qu'un an pour faire un rapport
d'état de la dette est raisonnable six
mois le but est d'arriver quand même à
quelque chose qui ait un sens et une
finalité donc c'est une sorte d'abandon
d'un amendement de repli on propose sous
un an mais nous nous satisfont riom de
l'adoption des précédents amendement
merci maintenant le 120 amendement 120
c'est monsieur finale qu'ils présentent
merci
donc bien durant la dernière décennie
les gouvernements successifs malgré des
besoins croissants de maintenance et de
régénération du réseau ont privilégié le
développement des lignes à grande
vitesse le précédent gouvernement a
poussé cette logique à l'extrême en
décidant la construction sans
financements correspondants de quatre
lignes lgv et a fait adopter instit
évalué à 260 milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui la dette de la sncf s'élève
à 7,3 milliards d'euros mais elle est
contrôlée et en réduction régulière en
revanche le stock si si le stock de la
dette de rff s'élève à 33,7 milliards
d'euros et s'accroît de 1 milliard 5 par
an et elle est estimée à 68 il ya ces
chiffres sont connus d'ici 2025 en
prenant en compte les quatre lignes tgv
lgv que je viens d'évoquer la mise en
place de la commission mobilité 21 a
permis de hiérarchiser de prévoir les
financement des futurs projets lgv est
de mettre l'accent sur la modernisation
du réseau existant ce projet de loi
constitue une seconde étape avec la
stabilisation financière il met
notamment en place une clause
prudentielles doublement innovantes tout
d'abord parce que à la différence de
cette mise en place en 1997 qui a connu
du succès que l'on sait que l'on sait la
règle d'or permettra de remédier aux
situations financières a posteriori
ensuite parce que cette règle d'or en
compte l'augmentation des revenus des
redevances d'infrastructures restent le
stock la question du stock de la dette
ont selon les critères d'eurostat tu la
dette historique de rff ne fait pas
partie de la dette de l'état français
récemment l'insee a proposé de
requalifier 10 milliards 8 de cette
dette
pour qu'elle soit reprise par l'état
ainsi l'article de terre à de pelé a
adopté la somme nationale prévoit la
remise d'un rapport sur les solutions
permettant de traiter l'évolution de la
date historique du système ferroviaire
en commission
développement durable nous avons prévu à
une sétif du rapporteur notre brillant
rapporteur que ce rapport examine ça
fait du bien après midi comme sahin
examine la possibilité d'une reprise de
tout ou partie de la dette du système
ferroviaire par l'état cet amendement
revenons à l'amendement que je propose
vise à ce que ce rapport envisage
également l'opportunité de créer une
caisse d'amortissement qui pourrait
porter tout ou partie de la dette
historique de rff et qui bénéficierait
d'une d'un financement pérenne comme
cela est le cas pour la cades est ce la
caisse d'amortissement pour la dette
sociale ce serait un signe fort chacun
en conviendra ici
la création d'une telle caisse qui
permettrait de faire baisser les charges
financières qui pèsent sur le
gestionnaire d'infrastructure 10
milliards 8 ans - cela représenterait
évidemment quelque chose de très
substantiels et je sais que les
cheminots il serait très attentif
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
la commission sur ces quatre amendement
l'amendement
prévoit d'abord
la remise d'un rapport du gouvernement
sur la dette dans un délai de six mois à
compter de la promulgation de la loi et
ensuite
élargi son contenu à l'examen de la
création d'une structure c'est le terme
employé d'amortissement de la dette
ferroviaire
la commission du développement durable a
émis un avis défavorable sur la première
partie de la manne moi parce que des
chinois lui paraît beaucoup trop court
il faudra disposer d'un délai plus long
pour pouvoir
effectivement apprécié les premiers
effets de la réforme ferroviaire quant à
la seconde partie il lui a semblé que la
formulation structure d'amortissement et
est moins précise que ce qui est indiqué
dans l'amendement numéro 120 du groupe
socialiste sur lequel je reviendrai tout
à l'heure
l'amendement 91 du groupe udi us et
prévoit également la remise du rapport
du gouvernement dans un délai de six
mois à compter la promulgation de la loi
même avis défavorable dans ces
conditions et pour les mêmes raisons de
la commission du développement durable
amendement 152 du groupe écologiste
alors là comme andré gattolin l'a
expliqué dans une logique de compromis
plus exactement le terme qu'il a
utilisée à l'instant
nos collègues écologistes ont
retenu plutôt le délai d'un an à côté la
promulgation de la loi là encore la
commission a trouvé que c'était quand
même un délai trop court et qu'il faudra
bien les deux ans tels qu'ils sont
prévus dans le projet de loi à l'heure
actuelle derniers amendements le 120
déposé par le groupe socialiste et
présenté par jean jacques filleul cet
amendement inclus dans le rapport du
gouvernement au parlement sur la dette
l'examen de l'opportunité de créer une
caisse d'amortissement de servières et
me tournant également vers les collègues
comme je leur dis que c'est la formule
exacte qui est qui doit être utilisée
par ailleurs évidemment cet amendement
al'avantage de permettre l'examen de
toutes les pistes possibles pour réduire
l'aide ferroviaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle sur cet aspect donc
amortissement de la dette la commission
a préféré l'amendement du groupe
socialiste à la seconde partie de
l'amendement du groupe communiste
merci monsieur le ministre
je souscris aux propos de monsieur
filleul sur la qualité du travail
réalisé par monsieur le rapporteur et
d'ailleurs j'en veux pour démonstration
la vie que le gouvernement donnera sur
les différents amendements et je me
limiterai simplement à donner la vie
puisque vous avez expliciter la position
à laquelle je me range c'est à dire sur
l'amendement soixante et un avis
défavorable 91 avis défavorable cent
cinquante deux avis défavorables
pour ce qui est de l'amendement 120 nous
considérons que tout en partageant me
suffit à l'objectif qui est le vôtre et
nous y souscrivons bien évidemment qui
est celle de pouvoir traiter
d'envisager toutes les solutions
possibles pour le traitement de la dette
du système ferroviaire nous considérons
que la rédaction actuelle
semble suffisante
le dernier j'ai précisé que le rapport
je cite examine les conditions de
reprise de tout ou partie de cette dette
par l'état cela comprend notamment la
création d'une caisse tel que vous le
souhaitez donc écoutez je m'en remettrai
à la sagesse concernant votre amendement
merci bien je vais mettre aux voix ces
différences avant de marquer
je vais faire vite j'ai un regret un
accord le regret c'est que les
amendements raccourcissant le délai
avant que les rapports ne soit rendu ne
fassent pas l'objet d'avis favorables
mais j'ai un accord sur l'amendement que
jean jacques filleul à a présenté au nom
du groupe socialiste qui me paraît
donner une piste tout à fait
intéressante sur la question du
traitement de la dette donc je voterai
l'amendement 120
je vois votre il s'en va
voilà pour l'examen de la réforme
ferroviaire vous pourrez revoir cette
séance à tout moment sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée à tous
sur notre chaîne
chaque année à la pentecôte la feria de
nîmes à six reprises